we begin in Russia where the Kremlin is
yet to confirm the death of the leader
of the Wagner mercenary group yevgeny
plaguardian was listed as being among
seven passengers and the three crew of a
private jet that crashed north of Moscow
Russia's Aviation agency says there were
no survivors eight bodies have been
recovered so far crash investigators
haven't confirmed that prague's body has
been found all that he was killed the
crash comes two months after the
longtime Ally of Russian President
Vladimir Putin that the short-lived
Wagner Mutiny against military leaders
in Moscow Laura Khan Recaps the latest
developments surrounding pragossians
reported death
this is the moment that the Embraer
aircraft jet came hurtling from the sky
in the tavir region north of Moscow
all 10 people including three crew
members were killed
Russia's Aviation agency has confirmed
that the Wagner military group boss
yevgeny burgosian was among the
passengers flying from Moscow to Saint
Petersburg
local reports state two loud bangs were
heard and multiple videos posted on
social media appeared to show the jet on
fire
this flight radar map shows the moment
it disappeared
the remains of all ten bodies have been
retrieved from the site and a criminal
investigation is underway
the main investigation department of the
investigative Committee of the Russian
Federation initiated a criminal case on
the fact of an aviation accident in the
TV region on the grounds of a crime
under article 263 of the criminal code
of the Russian Federation we're about
just two days before pagosian shared his
first video since his aborted Mutiny
against Russia's armed forces in June
Russian emergency services are looking
at two theories a possible explosion on
the plane and they are probing into the
Region's air defense systems loracan Al
Jazeera
at Al jazeera's Amin delgami is at the
scene of the crash in the tavare region
we can confirm that two vehicles arrived
at the crash site to transport the Dead
the Russian authorities confirmed
earlier they've retrieved eight bodies
two remain missing as the area is
heavily forested in as many lakes and
rivers
cars returned as you can see to continue
the search
parts of the plane were found two
kilometers away but it's difficult to
complete the search quickly the Russian
authorities have confirmed pagosian was
on board the flight
the Russian Aviation Federation released
the passenger list earlier seven a
Wagner members with three air crew until
now the investigation team has not
confirmed that pagosian's body has been
found or that he was killed in the crash
well let's go to our correspondent Rob
McBride he's joining us live from the
Ukrainian Capital cave so what's been
the reaction there to progression's
death Rob given his role in the war
yeah there's been a very little in the
way of an official reaction soon after
the news broke here and people are
following this as you would expect very
closely we had a statement from Michaela
podoliak he's a a a representative of
the president's office saying that this
shows that disloyalty equals Death In
His words I think generally in here in
Ukraine there will be very few tears
shed for yegeni pregogin given his track
record with his Wagner group of these
brutal assaults that they waged for many
months on the Eastern Front especially
around the uh city of bakmud for the
administration here for the military I
think the interest now comes uh is what
this will Herald inside Russia itself
does this now start a new round or new
episode of instability
um people have been following any
possible reaction from the Wagner units
uh the Wagner units that are sitting up
in their camps north of here in uh
Belarus other Wagner units who may have
returned to Russia itself whether they
are going to be taking any action any
retaliation there have been some chatter
on online chatter from people purporting
to be Wagner rights threatening
retaliation but it's difficult to verify
those actual Clips so that would be the
concern for people here and also for the
concern for people uh the Russian
military they remember of course the
disruption that was resulted from the
Wagner group taking over the city of
rostov on Dom which is the main Russian
hub for the military coming in and
coming out of Ukraine
um that has a very debilitating effect
on the morale of Russian soldiers
sitting in trenches along the front line
here in Ukraine for that reason Russia
doesn't want to repeat of that and for
the very same reason obviously Ukraine
would like to see a return of that sort
of disruption all right Robin Ukraine
marking Independence Day as the country
continues to be attacked
yeah absolutely that's probably we have
more concern on people's minds here on
this day it's Independence Day and
obviously it is richly symbolic coming
in the middle of this uh raging War
threatening that very Independence it's
the second timer that uh Ukraine has
marked independence day since the
full-scale invasion uh by Russia we are
not expecting any full-scale uh events
to take place as we have in previous
years I mean the concern for the
authorities here is that if they do
stage large-scale events with many
people if there are any attacks then
obviously that could result in many
casualties so it will be fairly low-key
fairly muted but it will be celebrated
and marked here uh in Kiev and cities
throughout Ukraine uh nonetheless there
has been a message from Vladimir
zielinski the Russian president a video
message saying this is the day of the
three he says the strong and the
dignified the concern is that Russia May
also try to mark this day with renewed
attacks so the air defenses and the
authorities here very much on their
guard all right Rob thank you very much
for that Rob McBride live and Keith